[music]
Watch me.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Give me a moment.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey you. Hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Is that is that pharmacist Ben?
>> Yes sir. The one and only famous and
important.
>> Yes. Extremely important.
>> That's me.
>> Almost so famous that you got to wear
shades. How are you today?
>> I'm good. Good to see you.
>> Yeah, good to see you.
>> AJ A juice.
>> Apple juice.
>> It It's been a little while and I hope
that the folks are out on the platforms
because they had to listen to me for 45
minutes last week and I'm sure that they
uh
>> Oh yeah. What did you talk about?
>> Are thrilled that you are here.
>> What'd you talk about?
>> What did I talk about? Um,
you know, the days run into each other.
Uh, I did talk a little bit about, uh,
uh, some of the things that, you know,
uh, you and I discuss often, you know.
Um,
>> yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I played a couple of these videos that
show some, uh, mechanics of the body and
told folks that they
>> You did it by yourself. You did the show
by yourself.
Not the show. I did a show because we
had people uh waiting.
>> That's awesome.
>> Good for you.
>> Uh I don't know. But you know, I
interviewed Jonathan Eort on Friday.
>> How did that go? I love Jonathan.
>> That's it. Went pretty darn good, I
think.
>> Yeah, he's he's good.
>> He's good.
>> He he
>> I think he ran for senator a couple
years ago.
He did run for Senate last year and he
he mentioned how he was
uh fortunate that he didn't get elected
because it's a pay cut, right?
>> It's a pay cut. That's true. Not
necessarily these days though.
>> I know, right?
>> Not necessarily. Not necessarily. It
should be a pay cut.
>> I I didn't go into the fact that Yeah,
he could have found some
>> all that insider stuff.
>> Yeah, that's a nasty business. those
politics baloney. Speaking of politics,
I've been Have you heard from our
senator friend um in Florida? Excuse me,
in Florida.
>> Of course. Why?
>> You talked to him all the time.
>> Uh I spoke to him recently. Why?
>> No, I just wondering. I talked to him a
couple weeks ago.
>> Yeah. You know, I think I think um
>> you realize it's been up like a month
since we've been went down there.
>> Yeah. But I think he's looking forward
to uh us really building out me really
building out his uh downline
>> downline. Do you have to go to Florida
to do it?
>> No to do it, but I need to uh
uh be more attentive to do it.
>> Yeah. Well, you're doing so many things.
I I do have quite a number of things on
my plate, but um
>> you ever see that movie Limitless?
>> I've been meaning to. It's about um it's
about Modana from what I I was just
listening to somebody talk about that.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> New Tropics. It's about Madan. I mean,
not literally about Madanaphil, but that
was the model for it. What What made you
think about that? it because the guy
because there there's this like really
um
uh borish type of uh Eastern European
guy who
uh who gets his hands on the super drug
and he says
because now now he's got more
intelligence now he's got the I got a
lot on my plate as he's as he's
preparing to chop the guy up you know
you're lucky I made time for you I got a
lot on my plate
I see it.
>> At any rate, uh this is a great mo great
movie. Who's Grace? Okay. Wyoming Annie
is asking
>> Wyoming Annie. What's up, Wyoming Annie?
>> She's making fun of my title.
Uh
we my title of tonight's show is
get older with grace because the other
way sucks.
>> Who's Grace?
>> Right. That's what Annie said.
>> That's exactly what
>> I want to get older with Grace.
>> Right. Well, you know, um
yeah, that that that's our goal, right?
We want to get older and uh feel good
and um
>> yeah, you want to feel good. You don't
want to age rapidly at an accelerated
pace and you don't want to fall apart
physically
or cognitively, mentally. You don't want
to fall apart. You want to gradually
go off, you know, die gradually. My mom
is 92. You know, I was just in New York
for for a week with my mom. and she's
just deteriorating so fast. It just
reminds me every time I see her that I
got I'm taking care of myself. I am
going to be doing, you know, there's no
sure thing I, you know, you never know
what awaits you, what fate awaits you,
but I'm going to do everything I could
do so I could just go into aging as
gracefully as as I can. And that's why I
always tell people
it's not, you know, we focus on sick
people, but healthy people need
supplementation and digestive and
dietary strategies so they don't get
sick so they can stay healthy. Yeah, you
we you can do a lot of things if you're
sick to to reverse to get healthy, but
sick healthy people need to be need to
be taking care of their supplementation
and dietary needs, etc. Um so they don't
get sick. So they don't have to deal
with a chronic illness. Chronic illness,
even though it seems like it's normal
and it has been normalized, you know,
more people have chronic diseases than
don't,
they're not normal. They're abnormal.
And human beings are not supposed to be
dealing with chronic degenerative
diseases. That's an aberration.
Um,
you know, you and and that is um
interesting. You know, I I know a lot of
people go back to the Bible. I go back
and I read those Sumerian tablets. I
think those stories are great regardless
if they're true or not.
>> What do you read? What are you reading
the Sumerian texts for?
>> And uh they talk about this one guy. I
think it's uh Enlil. And he
>> Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait. What
are you throwing out of the Enlil
reference here?
>> I'm sorry.
>> En
those
>> He wasn't a guy. He wasn't a guy. He's a
dude for these dude
>> for the purposes of these stories.
>> Okay. All right.
>> He's the dude
>> and he's he's procreating at
>> hundreds of years old
>> and and and looking studly enough that
the that the the young Phillies think
that he's uh
>> Is that what it says in the Sumerian
text?
>> It does.
>> It talks about Enlil just just playing
around. just can't control himself.
>> Can't control himself. All right. You
know, his brother, I think it was his
brother, Anki, was the god of healing.
[clears throat]
>> Enlil was the god of destruction.
>> Also, he also did agriculture. But but
but he was the god of destructive
storms.
>> Uh I think it's
>> and calamity, famine.
>> I think it's
>> flood.
Enlil is the flood guy. You're saying
it's the opposite.
>> I'll bet you Enl. Enlil told Zazudra
that there was going to be a flood.
>> Yeah. Enlil is the guy who was
responsible for tornadoes and storms.
>> Uh anyway,
>> so back health and nutrition.
[laughter]
Uh
um
Bernardette, what's your opinion on
urine therapy?
It's awesome. I've been meaning to talk
about that actually. Urine
urine is loaded with anti-aging and
healing substances. Stem cells, exoomes,
growth factors, peptides. I mean your
urine. Drink your urine, man. [laughter]
>> I'm serious.
>> And fix your gut with some feces, right?
Some
>> feal feal transplants and drink your
teal transplants here.
Hey, you know, who needs nutrition
>> when you got when you got fecal
transplants? Now, they also have they
also have feal capsules that you can
take orally.
>> Oh, man.
>> Yeah. You can literally eat.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> Oh, man.
>> No, urine therapy though, it's it's
really it's good stuff. I mean, if you
go past the fact that it's a waste
product, you know, it's clean and people
are drinking it for years. Urine therapy
has been, you know, for probably
thousands of years, certainly hundreds
of years, urine therapy, but it's loaded
with healing and anti-aging substances,
growth substances, regenerative
substances.
>> I've known that for many years. And if
you ferment the um the the urine, the uh
stem cells multiply.
>> Is that true? Are you making that up?
>> I didn't know that. That's news.
>> You know, I I I think I might have told
the story. It's kind of funny. when I
had my uh maybe 30 years ago, a guy in
Bold a doctor in Boulder who had
invented or not invented but had he uh
he discovered a molecule in broccoli
called DIM
>> which is now you and he patented it. He
I don't know if he patented he patented
the manufacturing of it and he was
experimenting with it. He wanted me to
be one of the first guys to experiment
with it. You can now get DIM everywhere.
It's it's an anti It's an estrogen
blocker. Supports estrogen metabolism.
It's called DIM. It's found in broccoli
and cruciferous vegetables. Anyway, he
wanted me to to take his DIM. Then he
was going to check my urine to check for
my stero my steroids and and DIIM, etc.
So, I had to do his DIM and I had to pee
into a a a gallon jug, like a gallon
water jug, because he was going to check
my urine at the end. So, he he needed a
bunch of my urine to check it. So, I I
would have to carry I I spent a day pee
into this gallon jug. And I remember
that night I went with my girlfriend at
the time to this fancy French restaurant
>> with my gall.
>> No, I left it there. I accidentally I
accidentally [laughter]
left it there.
And I always wondered who who would
discover [laughter] who would discover
my gallon jug of urine.
>> This guy.
You're not gonna believe what we found
at table 14. That guy, man. A gallon jug
of pee.
>> That's horrible. That's horrible.
>> I know it's fancy restaurant. So anyway,
>> no.
>> What's going on? Who do we have?
>> Urine. therapy is you can't it's not
going to substitute for supplements
because unless you take a lot of sub I
wouldn't I wouldn't count on it for
supplements but for biochemicals that
are important for growth and
regeneration and healing and and
fighting disease um urine is a great
source of those particularly steroids
hop on Rumble said can we mix it with
our BTT
Uh yeah, you can do that. You can do
that. Look, I I'm not going to tell you
that I'm that I am um you know, I would
do it, but it makes sense. You know,
>> does it? You think it makes sense?
>> Yeah, of course it does.
>> This show is for educational purposes
only. The content is not meant to
diagnose, treat, or cure any disease.
>> Why are you saying that?
>> Nor is it
>> Why? Why do you got to say that? Why do
you got to say that?
>> Because I gotta say it, you know. Is
Becca Becca on your case? Where is
Becca?
>> Uh Becca is still in Washington to my
knowledge.
>> Okay, gotcha. Where's Ruthellen?
>> Uh Ruth Ellen had to do a show earlier
today, so probably all showed out.
>> Where's Key?
>> Key's probably sick of me. Saw me
Saturday.
>> Where are those uh where are those
pretty pretty uh two black sisters?
Remember they used to come on the show?
>> Interesting. Uh, one's a client. The
other
>> me earlier. The mom is a client.
>> Okay. What were their names? Kiara and
and something. Key and Kiara or Kiara
and
>> Kiana and Kiana.
>> Uh, she's gonna kill me for not. Uh,
Kiana. Kiana is easy. That's my sister's
name. Uh, it's Kiana and
Kenya.
>> Kenya.
and their mom is Anuanette and uh I I
think their mom is so nice and uh
we will we are currently assisting them
with their nutrition and the other uh
will be soon.
Um,
you know, the questions that have come
in, pharmacist Ben, are all age related
questions. And I just want to remind
folks before I go into these questions.
>> Yes.
>> That um there's an opportunity for you
to help people um and help them uh to
age better. And you can do so
uh by joining us. And if you'd like to
join us as a health coach or distributor
and learn directly from uh the teachings
of pharmacist Ben and Dr. Wallik, please
email us at questions at
dealingwithdoc.com
and just say, you know what,
I'm tired of sitting on the sideline. I
want to help uh some folks. Uh I know
Bruce is watching. Uh Bruce will still
tell you that we have the ability uh to
help folks. Um
you know, we are we are doing it and you
know, you can be as as handson as you
like. Uh we like it when you're hands-on
and have all the education as that you
can. That way you can do it on your own.
Uh but we will hold your hand as long as
necessary. What do you have to say about
building a business?
uh pharmacist.
>> You know, I always thought that the best
businesses are the businesses that make
a real difference in people's lives at
at basic fundamental levels, financially
perhaps, um legally maybe, but
definitely in terms of your health. And
that's what longevity is. It's a
business where you can make money, but
at the other end of the equation are
people who are getting off their drugs
or who are losing weight or or who are
reversing their autoimmune diseases or
who are having better skin and bone and
energy and you know just overall
deceleration or slowing down of the
aging process. To me, that's the ideal
business opportunity. There's lots of
businesses. You could be a you can have
a landscaping business. You know, you
could have a a uh a janitorial business.
You can have a a cooking business. You
could have all kinds of businesses, but
to help people with their health, that's
an angel business. You're you're in the
angel business. Then you're helping
people at the most basic and fundamental
level there is. Look, I don't have a
chronic degenerative disease. You don't
have a chronic degenerative disease. Can
you imagine what that must be like to
wake up every day with some kind of
autoimmune problem and the doctors can't
help you and you're just degenerating
and degenerating and degenerating like
multiple sclerosis and you know that a
wheelchair is ahead of you and there's
no way you can have any kind of medical
intervention that's going to improve it.
That's got to eat at you. especially if
you have a family, if you have kids, you
know, if you to to be able to share the
information that we share on this
program and to be able to provide
nutritional supplementation that is so
transformative and life-changing. I feel
so blessed to be part of this business.
Not to mention the fact that you it's a
business. You make money and you can
write off your home office. I write off
my I wrote off my computer monitor. I
write off the a portion of the rent of
my house. You know, you I write off a
portion of my mileage. There's so many
ways that you can benefit from a
longevity business personally in terms
of just feeling good about yourself
intelligently by learning about how to
use nutrition for yourself and for your
family, financially in terms of money,
and perhaps most importantly of all by
making a positive difference in the
world. And we can help you.
We can help you do that.
>> You should tell your story. AJ, you
should tell I'm sorry. Let me just say
this real quick. You should tell your
story. You know, you have a great story.
I I don't think you've told it for a
while, have you?
>> How I got into Youngevity?
>> Yeah, it's a great story and it's
classic.
>> Um,
why why don't you why don't you
paraphrase the story and I'll fill you
in. I'm I'm curious to know which part
you like.
I like the part where
you bought the product, you had it
sitting there, you didn't take it, and
one of your friends came by and started
taking it and he fell in love with the
product.
>> That's not how it happened. I would
never let products sit. But I did
purchase it from my cousin.
>> Okay.
>> I purchased some products from my cousin
initially
>> and he didn't take it.
>> He didn't take it. He took a sip of
tangerine. like and he didn't take it.
>> But
uh I never thought the products would be
helpful for me, but I wanted to do a
business. I wanted to sell rebound.
I thought that I could sell Rebound and
make a billion dollars because I thought
that all the um sports teams around the
country would want a product that could
help save uh young athletes from
cardiomyopic heart attacks.
So, I bought stuff, but because I had a
cracked hip at the time and I couldn't
really get around,
uh, it came with so much product when I,
you know, you had to, you know, get the
pack or whatever, the distributor pack,
and it came with like $500 worth of
product or $600 worth of product for 500
bucks. I um couldn't really get around
so much, so I just started taking it.
Like, I couldn't It wasn't that I hadn't
tried it. I tried it, but then once I
tasted it, I was like, "Well, this is
good.
>> Let me try this one. This tastes good.
Oh, let me try this." And I just kept,
>> you know, just kept flooding myself with
this stuff.
>> And how'd you feel?
>> And within about 10 days, I was playing
basketball from not being able to walk
two successive days for work. Like I had
to Monday.
>> And you're And you're playing full
court. fullcourt basketball and and and
the kids thought I was Michael Jordan.
>> Literally, they were like, "Who is this
dude?"
>> Can Can you dunk?
>> Not today. [laughter]
>> Could you at one time?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> No, don't say of course.
>> Of course.
>> You could dunk. You could You could jump
You could get yourself over the rip.
>> I I played at the highest highest levels
in New York City basketball.
>> Seriously?
>> Yeah. Did I ever tell you, you know,
there was this girl Did I ever tell you
the story about the girl played
basketball in my neighborhood?
>> No.
>> When I when I lived in Queens and uh
there were a bunch of like the Yankees
lived there in Queens, Walt, this guy
Walt Williams, a few of a few of them.
And they would we would all play
basketball. I was like I was in high
school. I was in high school at the
time. And so we would all play
basketball at this at the school. And
there was this girl and she would come
and she would beat everybody oneon-one.
and she was just massively incredible.
And we were all like blown away with
this girl. We would watch her. Everybody
would hang out and crowd crowds would
gather to watch this girl play
one-on-one with the Yankee players. Uh
and uh she ended up being Nancy
Lieberman.
>> No.
>> Yeah. Who's the considered to be
>> Yeah. She was right in my neighborhood
in Queens.
>> Oh wow. I had no idea.
>> Yeah. Yeah. In the 70s. You know, she
coaches she coaches in the big three
now.
>> Who does she coach for?
>> So, the big three is a threeon-ree
basketball tournament that this guy Ice
Cube created.
>> It's called the Big Three.
>> The Big Three is a threeon three.
>> Ice Cube. Ice Cube. The guy from
Barershop.
>> The Yes. The rapper Ice Cube. Yes.
>> I just remember Barershop.
>> Barershop. Yes. Him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's great in
Barershop. I don't I I like I'm gonna
watch that tonight now that I think
about it. That was a good movie.
>> Yeah. Well, he's got And
>> there's another Ice. There's Ice Cube
and there's Ice Trey or Ice something.
>> Ice Tea.
>> Ice Tea. Ice Tea. Is he That's the other
rapper.
>> Yeah, I see. I
I feel that way.
>> But Nancy Lieberman and um Cheryl Miller
were like
>> they were so good that
>> I I I I was starruck with them. Like
>> you were Yeah. Nancy
>> like regular like like like men like
male basketball players. If I saw
>> I saw Cheryl Miller,
>> I would be just as
I saw Patrick Huitt. Like it would it
would be the same.
>> Oh, I'm telling you, people crowds would
watch Nancy. She would do spin dunks.
>> She would spin and dunk.
>> She could dunk.
>> She could dunk. [laughter]
>> She could dunk. And she would spin and
dunk.
>> She was amazing.
>> Yeah, she was. She was uh amazing.
Bernardet, I don't know how old you are,
Bernardet, but we can help you in
Ireland. You need to email us.
>> What's What's Bernadette talking about?
And we have, you know, we were, this
isn't about, you know, this show, this
show is not about me and you
chitchatting. We got to help the people.
>> You don't want to hear us chitchatting.
Bernardet, how can we help you?
>> Bernardet, email us at
questionsailywithdoc.com.
And Bernardet is dealing with
I I think she said heart palpitations.
Let me find this again. Bernardet is
dealing with
uh I guess uh SVT heart condition. Is
that uh
>> Yeah. Yeah. She's got a heart problem.
Her heart's racing. Tachi cardia.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Ventric ventricular tachicardia. So her
heart's racing.
>> What does the S stand for though?
>> Supra ventricular.
>> I'm pretty sure. Super ventricular
tachard.
>> She's got heart palpitations.
>> Yeah, that's all. It's her heart's not
getting what it needs. Why? Because
she's got dirty blood. Remember, all
disease is cell disease, but all cell
disease is preceded by dirty blood. I
know I say it every time. I say it
again. It's all about the blood. The
life of the flesh is in the blood. Why
is heart disease the leading killer in
the world across the world? Why is heart
disease the leading killer? Because
everybody has dirty blood. When the
blood is dirty, when I say dirty, burnt,
I'm talking about sugar dirt. I'm
talking about digestive toxin dirt. I'm
talking about def nutrient deficiency
dirt. And I'm talking about um hypoxia,
low levels of oxygen dirt. So low levels
of oxygen, sugar, toxicity from the
digestive system. Um all of these will
conspire to malnourishment, mal uh lack
of nutrients. All of these will conspire
to put a stress on the heart. Listen,
the heart when it pumps
and it pumps like a billion times in a
person's lifetime. How does a heart
pump? How does this happen? Individual
cells in the heart have to conduct
electrical energy like a battery in this
perfectly
synchronized
fashion. Perfectly synchronized.
And in order for that to happen,
countless
countless there's no way to come up with
the number of trillions, gazillions,
bazillions, whatever. Countless tiny
little chemical reactions and electrical
reactions have to happen perfectly.
When they do computer chips, you
probably know this, AJ, when they make
computer chips, they got to wear these
hazmat gowns where they're covered head
to toe. There's no skin exposed and
they're in these special rooms with
special filters that and they have to
spe they have to wear special boots and
the floor has to be made of special
rubber because if a piece of dust gets
in a computer chip, it's trashed. A
microscopic piece of dust will destroy a
computer chip. Well, your blood is more
even more sensitive than that and cells
are even more sensitive than that. So
once you start to get inflammatory
factors in the blood, dirt, once you
start to get low levels of oxygen in the
blood, once you start dealing with
malnourishment and high concentrations
of sugar and the blood chemistry is
disturbed,
it becomes very difficult if not
impossible for that energy to be
conducted appropriately through the
heart. Now, that's the mechanism and I
find it incredibly fascinating and I
think we should all be studying these
mechanisms, but you don't need to
understand it. I'm only telling you the
mechanism so that you can see when I say
clean the blood, I'm not just talking
out of my butt. I'm not just saying like
repeating my, you know, repeating some
kind of jargon or slogan. I'm telling
you how it happens. So Bernardet, if you
want to correct this problem, you can
correct it easily simply by slow deep
breathing to get some oxygen in the
system. Moving your body around also
helps get oxygen into the system. Making
sure you're using nutrients, especially
electrical nutrients like your plant
derived minerals as well as the B
complex of vitamins and essential fatty
acids and magnesium and zinc and
selenium, a whole slew of them. Number
three, reduce your sugar intake
dramatically and treat yourself like a
diet
sugar pack uh in addition to the healthy
brain and heart pack. And then um if you
have any digestive health issues, you
correct those digestive health issues.
Now, I've given you four steps,
Bernardet, that I'm guaranteeing you
100% if you practice your slow deep
breathing and move your body around to
get some oxygen and you get on
nutritional supplement program, AJ can
tell you what to do. You reduce your
sugar intake and you treat yourself like
a diabetic, get on the healthy blood
sugar pack, use nutrients for for blood
sugar, and correct digestive problems.
I'm guaranteeing you 100% that you will
correct your ventricular tachicardia or
at least slow it down. Guaranteeing you
and you'll do it not only with no
toxicity but you'll get added benefits.
Now you're in Ireland and you're
probably unfortunately in Europe. You're
immer immersed in the medical model
because it's all free over there. So I
doubt you know I don't want to say that.
I'd be surprised if you do all these
things because most people don't. I'm
not knocking you, Bernardet, because I
don't know you, but most people don't.
When they have free medicine and they
have free doctors and we've been
conditioned and programmed and
hypnotized to believe that the doctors
know everything and they can do whatever
and they're gods and they know how the
body works and you always go to the
doctor. You're not going to do any of
this stuff. But if you do do it, I'm
guaranteeing you that you're you can
begin to reverse your heart conditions
and add years to your life on top of it
in a non-toxic way that you handle
without having to go to the doctor. You
handle on your own.
>> Bernard Schlanban, uh, uh, pharmacist
Ben, is she required to stop smoking?
>> Is she smoking?
Is is Bernardet a smoker?
>> You see it on the screen?
>> No. Burn a debt.
Burn a debt.
How do I address that? [laughter]
>> I'm just wondering. I mean, because you
said you guaranteed.
>> No, no, you can [laughter] still smoke.
In fact, you should smoke an extra pack
a day just to make sure that you know. I
mean, look, every time you smoke a
cigarette, you want to gargle with
Beyond Tangy Tangerine.
>> Okay?
>> Every time you smoke a cigarette, you
deplete your body of vitamin C from
every cigarette you take, not to mention
other nutrients. After you smoke a
cigarette, gargle with vitamin C or
gargle with Beyond Tangy Tangerine and
then do a shot of Beyond Tangy Tangerine
to mitigate some of the damage. But come
on, you know, you can't It's very
diffic.
What's happening to your lungs?
>> I mean, does that mean like uh
>> vitamin? Well, there's more.
>> There's more. There's more. Vitam
vitamin C can help support collagen
production in the lungs. That's one
thing. But vitamin C can help the
detoxification system work. And in
addition to the mechanical damage from
the smoke in the lungs, you also have
metabolic damage. You have toxins. You
have all kinds of toxicity, including
heavy metals in the tobacco and in the
paper. So, you know, they they put
chemicals in the paper for the burning
so it doesn't burn really fast. You
know, cigarette burns very slowly. Paper
doesn't burn slowly. They got to put
chemicals in the paper so it burns
slowly. So, when you're drinking a when
you're smoking a cigarette, you're
smoking a cocktail of chemicals that are
going right in your blood. So, you can't
think there's very little thing you
could do to to shorten your life.
There's very few things that you could
do that will more effectively shorten
your life and cause misery than smoking.
So, I can't, you know, if you're
smoking, there's only so much you could
do. But that just makes it even more
important that you get on a nutritional
supplement program, practice your slow
deep breathing, u look out for digestive
issues. You know, it's like the immune
system and the metabolic system are like
a camel's back. If you start piling
stuff on the camel, cigarette smoke and
disbiosis and sugar, processed food and
emotional, psychological stresses on the
camel's back, it's going to break
eventually. But if you can pull things
off the camel's back, even if you have
10 things on the camel's back, if you
start pulling a couple off, it makes it
easier for the camel to survive. So, you
know, if you're going to smoke, at least
take your Beyond Tangy Tangerine and
reduce your intake of other foods. The
thing is of of of fast burning sugars
and and processed foods. The thing is,
and this is really interesting, people
who smoke,
there's psychological issues there as
well. Smoking is a way of stimulating
your chest,
your heart chakra, you know, and it's
it's it's a dysfunctional way, but it
does do that. And so sometimes people
will smoke. One of the reasons they
smoke is because they like the feeling
in their chest.
>> Goodness.
It has it's a love issue, I think. And
we think about what is smoke. You're
putting hot fire into your chest. That's
angry. You know, that's self-hate.
That's self- abuse. I'm not trying to
judge anybody or be psych, you know,
psychologically diagnose anybody, but
that's a lot of self um maliciousness to
put that fire in your chest, in your
heart, literally in your heart and in
your lungs. This is the key to
everything, your heart and your lungs.
and you're putting fire, not to mention
tar and toxins and all the other things
that are cigarette smoke. So, I think
there's some there's usually some
something going on psychologically
[snorts] with when people are doing that
to themselves, but I'm not that's not my
not that's not my business. From a
nutritional standpoint, you can mitigate
the damage with vitamin C, beyond tang
tangerine, vitamin E, netylcysteine,
selenium, glutamine, whey protein.
There's a lot of things you could do to
mitigate some of that damage. Keretin,
um, essential fats, essential fatty
acids. There's a lot you could do.
>> Why caretin?
>> Keretin supports vitamin C and it's an
adaptogen.
>> Keretin, I think, is on the co protocol
list.
>> Um,
>> yes,
>> this has been, I got a doozy. So, you've
spoken to these people before.
>> Yeah. What' you think of that
Parkinson's article by the way?
>> Uh I
uh again
>> Ben is right. I mean
um I can't quote the article fully, but
yes, that was part of the inspiration
for today's show. And I wish Do I have
it up?
>> Um and I will I will grab that in a
second.
>> How about that other article I sent you
about chronic disease and leaky gut?
Again, it's just
>> again, right? You know, here's the
thing, though. I don't have to wait for
studies. I don't have to wait for
articles because I'm doing engineering.
I'm not doing biology or chemistry. I'm
working backwards from an engineering
standpoint. And it's just makes sense
everything how everything's connected.
So, you don't need studies, but it's
just nice to be validated with them.
>> Yeah. Um
I it's just uh amazing that they will
say that you could potentially
benefit yourself by having vitamins when
it comes to Parkinson's disease. If you
just want to bear with me for a second,
this article here
uh and pharmacist Ben, can you not see
this article on the screen?
>> I see the article. Yeah, I see.
>> You see it?
>> Yeah, that's the one I sent you.
>> You couldn't see stuff last week for
some reason.
>> I couldn't.
>> Yeah, I would put stuff on the screen.
You couldn't see it. Anyway,
>> yeah.
>> Uh, [clears throat]
Parkinson disease the second most common
neurogenative disorder following
Alzheimer's. Clinically, PD is
characterized by resting tremor,
hypermyotonia,
postural instability, and breath.
>> What are you reading? What are you
reading here? Are you reading that
article? This is that article and find
>> Can you make it bigger or I can find it
if I I can find it. Let me find it here.
>> I got it. I have it on my computer.
>> Trying to make it bigger for the folks.
Let's see.
Um
Oh,
>> pathogenesis. What What are you reading?
Vitamin B and PD. uh benefits of
vitamins in in the treatment of
Parkinson.
>> Which part? Yeah, I know. But which part
of the paper were you just reading?
>> So, we're just the introduction
basically it's uh it talks about A, D,
E, and K.
Uh
>> de I call them dee the fats soluble
vitamins. Deak. And by the way, A and D
are hormones. They're not vitamins.
>> Did you know that? Have we talked about
that?
>> You may have mentioned it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Hor. What does that mean? That
means they actually make things happen.
Vitamins help. You can't chemical
reactions can't proceed without them,
but hormones make them happen. They're
orders of magnitude more powerful than a
vitamin. So vitamin A and D, they're
hormones. And not a day goes by
practically without some without some
discovery about vitamin D being related
to intestinal health and neurological
health and brain health and immune
system health and skin health and bone
health. You know why vitamin D is so
important as a hormone? Because vitamin
D is a major player in calcium
activation and metabolism. And calcium
perhap I you may know this uh u AJ but I
don't know if our listeners know it.
What did you do to this? Did you change
the way this is or is that me?
>> Does that change the
>> Did you change? No, the way I look on
the screen that's just me. I can't see
you. Um
anyway um uh calcium is an activator and
vitamin D is important for ca for
calcium to do its work. It supports
calcium entry into the bloodstream and
into cells. So vitamin D by virtue of
its ability to pro help the cells in the
body process calcium is good for
everything. It's important for
everything. And how ironic is it that
vitamin D is really a sunshine vitamin?
You know, I mean, you get vitamin D from
foods. That's true. But the main the
best way to get your vitamin D is from
the sun. You can supplement with vitamin
D. And there's vitamin D in certain
foods. Organ meats probably are the best
way. Skin, skin, chicken skins and
things like that, fish skins, liver, but
really, um, get yourself out in the sun.
Now, interestingly, African-Americans
are notorious for vitamin D deficiency,
and they're they suffer from vitamin D
deficiency health issues more than
Caucasians. Did you know this, AJ? I'm
familiar. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Because melanin as important as it
is will keep vitamin D from getting from
hitting the cells from hitting your it's
actually you know what it hits in the
cell you know what you know what
converts into vitamin D. How that works?
Cholesterol
>> in your skin is activated by vitamin D.
And vitamin D is a type of cholesterol.
Did you know that
>> it's a version of
>> it's now you know it. It's a version of
cholesterol. Next time some
knuckleheaded medical professional tells
you, "You got to lower your cholesterol,
you got to get that cholesterol down, we
got to get your cholesterol down." I
heard this comedian, he was like, "I
went to the doctor and I was kind of
scared to go to the doctor because, you
know, last year my my cholesterol was
high and and you know, and I hadn't done
anything different, so what are the odds
it's gonna it's going to go down?" And
he says, then he goes, "Yes, I went to
my doctor." And doctor says, "Um, have
you been watching your cholesterol?" And
and the guy, comedian Brian Rean, he
goes, "Oh, yeah. Yeah." He says,
"Meanwhile, he's got these Burger King
coupons in his pocket while he's saying
it." [laughter]
You know, but cholesterol is just so
silly. It's to There's so many things in
the culture that we take seriously that
are just so silly, silly, silly, silly.
This fascination with cholesterol.
Silly.
What is it that causes your cholesterol
to become disrupted? Sugar. That's what
you want to focus on. Cholesterol.
>> Oils.
>> And seed oils are a problem. You know, a
little different, but yes, seed oils are
a problem. Oils are a problem. And I've
been talking about since pharmacy school
in the 80s. I never I formulated
thousands of different skincare
products. Never once did I use a
vegetable oil in there.
Never. Vegetable oils are the worst
thing you can put on your skin. And you
eating too. frying the oils, deep frying
the oils.
It's terrible. It's awful from a from a
chemistry standpoint. It might be
delicious from a food standpoint. Do you
ever have Do you ever have a deep fried
turkey?
>> Possibly.
>> They're You would know they're pretty
freaking amazing. Deep fried turkeys.
>> I They take the turkey and they stick it
in just hot oil and let it cook for like
not even that long. I think like four
hours
>> burning themselves. Um,
>> what's Yeah, you got to watch out.
That's true.
>> They do burn oil
>> from that. Um,
uh, before I go into our one serious
question that we have, um, I was
watching, uh, Bloomberg today.
First of all, I was watching, uh,
Facebook yesterday
and
>> there's this guy uh, I think his name is
Yaki Awakened.
>> Yaki Awakened. Okay. pretty smart guy.
Pretty smart guy.
>> But he's making a distinction between
the nutritional needs of
African-Americans and
>> um
>> and white people,
>> Caucasians.
>> What? Like what's his point?
>> His point was we African-Americans can't
process
lactose was one of his points. You know,
that's interesting you say that because
the first people to use cows for milk
were Africans,
>> the Messiah.
>> And he said he said he said for this one
tribe,
>> the Messiah.
>> The Messiah.
>> I can't imagine it's the Messiah. It's
so
>> it's the No, it's the Messiah. They're
they're known for drinking dairy
>> and uh you know and uh so
uh said for that tribe no one else in
Africa you said can process
uh
>> nobody can Europeans can't either
>> there's some Scandinavians who can
>> Europeans can't pro nobody can very few
people can
>> right
>> it's just it you know it's just we've
lost animals
Milk is for babies to grow into adults.
But like urine, like with urine,
mother's milk, breast milk is so packed
with nutrients, it's the most amazing
health food. We should all have our own
breast to drink. He was saying
>> then he went on to say that the coconut
is shaped like a breast and
>> we should we should not be drinking
uh we should be drinking from the
coconut.
>> Well, the coconut's good, but it's not
going to give you everything you need
just cuz it's shaped like a breast.
>> He's saying that we should not be
consuming polysaccharides like a witter
in milk. And the first thing I thought
was zerical when he said that it was
>> no I don't I don't know what that guy's
talking about. The polysaccharides are
very regenerative and they stimulate the
growth of the nervous system and the
digestive system. So the polysaccharides
in milk are stellar. Unless he knows
something I don't know from a
biochemistry standpoint the
polysaccharides are the superstars of
the well it's hard to say because
there's so many good things in breast in
in mother's milk but the polysaccharides
are among the superstars of the
nutrition of the nutrients. So, I don't
know what this guy's talking about. Put
him on. Bring him on the show.
>> I Well, I'll try.
>> Yeah.
>> Does he know what he's talking about? Is
he I mean, is he well read? Does he know
what he's talking about?
>> Uh,
couple things.
>> Yeah. Sometimes people speak, you know,
they don't really know what they're
talking about. They just somebody told
them something or they believe
something, but it doesn't make sense.
So, I don't know if he knows what he's
talking about. But, I would I wouldn't
mind him coming on the show.
>> You ever hear Dr. Sebie? You remember?
>> Of course. Of course. I know Dr. I mean,
I don't know him personally.
>> He's kind of like
>> Dr. Sebby, you know, he was he was not
on he was not wrong very often. Dr.
Sebie, I like Dr. Sebie, you know,
he there was some things that I didn't
agree with Dr. Sebie, but he understood
the power of food. Dr. Sebie was really
he was really understood the power of
food and the power and the power of not
eating, the power of eating less, and
the power of fasting. Yeah, I like Dr.
Sebie, I have to say.
And and um you know the thing I found
flawed about what Sebie said was he was
talking about food uh in uh
I think his country was Panama. I forget
which country he lived in.
>> He was from Hondur He was from Honduras.
Dr.
>> Honduras his food is rich in nutrients.
So yeah, you can do all these things
with food in Honduras, which you can't
do in America.
>> That's very true.
>> Has no nutrition.
>> That's very true. That's very true.
Yeah. Uh Dr. Sebby, you know, he was all
right.
>> Um you know, he he
I wasn't 100% on board with Dr. Sebby.
He was he was all about plant-based.
That was his thing, right?
>> Okay. So for this guy um okay so
we we have um
uh a couple who you met in the past they
have a milrenown the husband's got a
milrenown drip do you know Millerown
>> Millerown oh mil oh he's he's on an IV
>> yeah for the hearts and it it caused an
infection
>> and and they're working now to get this
pump off of
to to stop the uh
>> that's what happens. You can't just
stick things in your body like that.
Milen is a inhibitor of a certain enzyme
and they use it for heart failure.
[clears throat]
>> And this enzyme inhibitor that they use
for heart failure, it increases the
contractions of the heart and relaxes
the blood vessels to improve blood flow.
Basically, that's what it does. So, they
use it for acute heart failure. If
you're at the point where you have acute
heart failure, you've been mucking
things up for a long time. If he's on an
IV drip, he's in the hospital, right?
>> No, at home is
>> at home. Oh, then you're home. Oh, okay.
Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha. Um, you know,
it's not without side effects. It's It's
pretty powerful stuff, but they give it
to you when they don't have any other
options.
>> Well, they're saying that
that his heart's stronger since he's
been on a nutritional supplementation
plan. And
>> you know, if I was him, first of all, to
get How old is he?
>> 70s. High 70s.
>> Okay. So, he's been mucking things up
for a little bit. Okay. So, what I would
be doing is I would be doing everything
we tell him to do with nutrition and
with diet and we can call he can call us
up. We can talk to him and then
gradually as his body gets stronger,
wean himself off the meds.
>> That's that's what they've been trying
to do.
>> Yeah. So get them on the healthy healthy
brain and hard pack,
>> healthy brain and heart pack, right?
Ultimate selenium, ultimate nascin.
Um, fucoid Z.
Uh, I take extra ultimate EFAs
like maybe 16 a day or 20 a day kind of
thing.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. A lot of them.
>> Because you don't get a lot in those
capsules don't have a lot in them. You
need
>> what's the importance of the EFA in
relation to this heart
>> anti oh my god everything
anti-inflammatory the the inflammation
system is controlled by the essential
fats I don't know about 20 that might be
a lot I take 12 or so and I don't really
have I'm just taking them so maybe 15 or
so but the point is is they're they
control the inflammatory system
inflammation
and anti-inflammation
are in tight balance you need both you
need inflammation you need
anti-inflammation and are balanced,
right? Many of the things we do today
encourage inflammation. That's what all
disease is inflammatory.
So using essential fatty acids is like
nature's aspirin. They're like natural
inflammatory balancers.
And that's what the EFAs do. They
reestablish inflammatory balance. It's
not a it's not cut and dry though how
much you need, how much omega 6 to omega
3 you need,
what uh what your health issues or your
lifestyle issues, the impact they're
going to have on how much you need. It's
not a sure thing with essential fats.
So, you got to play around with them a
little bit, but you need them. I've seen
dramatic things, particularly in the
skin, with essential fats.
>> I cut you off. You you were saying you
were running down things. You said
nascin. You said
>> for this for the guy with the heart
failure.
>> Yeah. N ultimate nascin ultimate
selenium. Ultimate EFAs. Fucoid Z.
Healthy brain and heart pack. Uh TMR
shake.
Uh
what else? There's probably some other
things I'm missing. There's other single
nutrients you can take. I take extra
thamin, extra arginine.
Um
what else here? Maybe some sweeties,
control the blood sugar, extra niacin
maybe.
Yeah, there's there's things you might
want to take extra singular of
>> besides the nasin plus.
>> Yeah. No, I take the nice plus, but
vitamin C in high doses can be helpful
like grams of vitamin C. That might be
something to think about too.
>> Vitamin C is very, very, very important
for the heart. Very. And a very
compelling case can be made that heart
disease is a form of
>> scurvy.
>> I'm not saying that I know that for a
fact, but a compelling case can be made
for that.
>> Yeah, it it um Okay. Uh what's a better
what's better for leaky gut? Nightly
essence or daily digest?
>> Uh I don't What's in the Daily Digest?
Uh, daily digest is
enzymes.
>> Enzymes. It's got enzymes and it's uh
>> I I there's probiotics in there, too, I
think. Right.
>> Yeah, there are some probiotics.
>> I would have to see. There's a new
probiotic supplement they just came out
with.
>> That one's for women only.
>> Oh, really? Like the
mean for women? What happens if a man
takes it? Will he grow breasts and uh
lady parts?
>> He'll he'll just become very sexy.
>> Yeah.
>> He'll want to have the surgery. He'll
want to have the surgery.
[clears throat]
>> Okay. Wait. So, the Daily Digest, by the
way, it's a true to life daily digest.
>> Yeah. I forgot. I don't I forgot what
the what's in the Daily Digest, but I
don't want to marginalize the nightly
essence. It's an amazing product.
They're both important. I don't want to
say one is more important than the
other. I guess if you had to pick one,
maybe the Daily Digest because it has
everything. But but I
>> It's got a lie capsule. It's got a
microbiome support capsule. And
>> I don't feel Yeah, I don't feel
comfortable saying Daily Digest instead
of I'd say both.
[clears throat]
>> Bromelene. Yeah, probably.
>> I I would say both. Yeah, I would say
both.
>> Okay, we got we got a question that just
came We got two questions just came in.
Uh, James James is saying, "Have two
small dimesized dry scaly patches in the
skin on my back. My chiropractor noticed
them recently. He said they were fungal
pack patches. What causes them and what
can be done about them?"
>> Say that again. He noticed patches on
his back and they were fungal in origin.
>> Uh, two small dimesiz dry patches.
>> I don't know that they're fungal. Uh
there could be a lot of things, but
assuming the doctor's right and they're
fungal, a couple things you can do.
First of all, you can go get Lotin or
Miconazol from the uh from the
drugstore. They're antifungals, topical
antifungals. Uh secondly, if you want to
do it for, you know, metabolically,
there's a balance between bacteria and
fungus. They live in balance with each
other. Uh bacteria control fungus,
fungus control bacteria. You know, a lot
of antibiotics come from fungus, from
fungi. Penicellin was derived from
fungi, you know, because fungi make
things to kill back bacteria and vice
versa.
You can go to the bathroom. I was think
what do you need? What do you need, sir?
What do you need, young?
>> Yeah. I I don't know if it was
penicellin. I was going to say
penicellin, but I went to the wedding.
>> Penicellin came from mold. Penicellin
came from mold.
>> I went I went to the wedding of a guy
who in whose father or grandfather
invented like penicellin or something
like that. No, he didn't invent penis.
>> I'm trying to tell you like it was it
was some it was some uh well-known
powerful drug that he invented in the
30s or 20s and we went to their wedding.
>> What was his last name?
>> Fleming. I think it was Fleming who
discovered
>> I I forget, but it was the biggest
synagogue
in Manhattan. Like the the on Fifth
Avenue. It's like so
>> whatever inherited.
>> It's funny you say that. It's funny you
say that because the 30 the 20s and 30s
were the glory days of pharmacy.
>> The 30s actually from the 20s to the 60s
were the glory days of pharmacy. By the
by the 70s it was starting to fade a
little bit. But from the 20s to the 60s
pharmacy could do no wrong. It was
miraculous what people could do with
drugs. And they drug companies made tons
of money. Drug stocks went crazy. You
know, they were considered like
magicians, people who could make drugs
and take care of d epilepsy and and
arthritis and autoimmune diseases and
such. They didn't know about the
downsides yet of the drugs. So, there
were a lot of drugs that came out in the
20s and 30s. It was really a very big a
time of great advancement in drugs,
particularly with antibiotics. But, as
far as the fungal guy goes, bacteria
make antifungals and fungals make
antibacteria. And when you're dealing
with disbiosis,
fungal infections can arise. Uh so
topically I would use miconazol or or
lotin or um you can get prescription
topical steroid betamethasone or
something like that. Uh or you could
just you know work on your look for
other symptoms that are usually
digestive and work with dispiosis.
>> All right, pharmacist Ben, I hope you're
sitting down.
>> Yes.
>> Because this is a tough question coming
in.
>> Okay. And I'm not I hope you're sitting.
>> I'm sitting.
>> Is there a way to heal the nerves
damaged by diabetes?
>> Yeah.
>> Which has caused retrograde ejaculation
>> for years.
>> Retro.
>> Retrograde. That means ejaculating
inside.
>> Or ejaculating late.
>> I don't know.
>> I don't know what retrograde means.
>> After the sun goes down. No, I'm just
>> I don't know what that I never heard
that term. Retrograde. I'll look it up
for us.
>> Look it up. Retrograde.
>> So, uh, for years, this is the part
you're sitting down for. For years, I
was, not that the other part wasn't
sitdown worthy, but this one. For years,
I was told that my intake of sugar
caused my diabetes to learn caused my
for years. I was told my intake of sugar
caused my diabetes. to learn that an
organism within the pancreas eats the
insulin produced which reduces this
insulin.
>> Hang on, hang on, hang on. An organism
within the pancreas. Did you say
>> saying there's some sort of parasitic uh
entity in the pancreas which is eating
his insulin uh which reduces the insulin
to the blood.
There must be some herbal supplement
which can destroy this organism living
and thriving within the pancreas and
there must be some herbal supplement
that can restore the nerve health to
soft tissue. I would like to your
thoughts on these two matters of my
concern. Thank you for your podcast and
products. I look forward to hearing any
advice you can share. By the way, um
Bernardet, you need to email me
questions dailywithdoc.com. I have help
for you in Ireland. Your thoughts on
this question we just read.
>> There are parasites uh parasitic
infections that can be found and
diabetes. People have diabetes their
metabolism is totally thrown off. So you
can't say that parasites cause the
diabetes any more than you can say the
diabetes causes the parasites. It's like
a chicken and egg thing. You know,
there's parasites present. People who
don't really understand chemistry will
say, "Oh, the parasites caused the
diabetes." But it could be the diabetes
led to a condition where the parasites
could overgrow because the the uh the
blood sugar system suppresses the immune
system and when you have diabetes, you
oftenimes have digestive issues. In
fact, they precede diabetes. So, I
wouldn't say the parasites are eating as
insulin. There is this I have heard that
there's parasites. Uh people who have
diabetes can have higher parasitic load
and everybody has parasites. They're
part of our microbiome. But I would not
go that's that's not right. That's not
right. Diabetes
is a brand name
for a biological condition called
dislycemia.
It's associated with insulin resistance.
That is a much more powerful place to
work than to worry about an herb that's
going to kill a parasite.
That's that's that's silly. So you want
to work on the insulin and by taking
nutritional supplements and reducing
your sugar load and lowering the blood
sugar by again using supplements,
reducing your sugar load, drinking more
water, using more uh being more uh
exercising more. As you exercise, sugar
gets shunted into the into the muscles
from the blood. It lowers your blood
sugar. And that's a much more
intelligent strategy than try to kill
parasites. Well, if you do all the
things I just said, not only you're
going to address your diabetes, but
you're going to live a longer life.
You're going to reduce your risk of
heart disease. You're going to reduce
your risk of autoimmune disease. You're
going to reduce your risk of cancer.
You're going to reduce your risk of of
of degen neurodeenerative conditions,
Alzheimer's disease, dementias, killing
parasites. That, you know, I don't even
want to address that. Uh, what's the
retrograde ejaculation?
Oh, man.
Is that like delayed ejaculation?
>> Ladder. Retrograde ejaculation is when
semen enters the bladder.
>> Oh, it goes the other way.
>> Exiting through the penis during orgasm.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it goes the other way. I
have heard of that. Um, and he's saying
it was nerve damage. While harmless, it
can cause male infertility caused by the
failure of the bladder sphincter to
close often due to nerve damage,
diabetes, MS, medications or surgery.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You can you can you know
depending on how severe the damage is,
you can definitely do things B vitamins,
ultimate EFAs,
um magnesium,
zinc,
cholesterol, phospholipids, lecithan,
those are all important. alpha lipoic
acid. Those are all things. It's like a
neuropathy. Thamin, you know, you've
heard of peripheral neuropathy.
>> Yes,
>> that's that's a different kind. And
peripheral neuropathies in the
periphery, the extremes, fingers, toes,
hands, feet. This is a different kind of
neuropathy, but it's still neuropathy.
Neuropathies and diabetes go hand in
hand because sugar damages the nerves.
So, you know, get off do all the
diabetes things. It's very simple.
Pharmacist Ben, when you talk about uh
maybe utilizing extra thamin, um what
what type of dosage are you talking
about for the average person?
>> 100 200 milligrams a day, 300 milligrams
a day, divided doses because you'll
urinate it out. The recommended daily
allowance is like I think 10 milligrams
or 15 milligrams. Ridiculous.
>> One of the best things you can do for
chronic constipation
is thamin. And I would say thin
deficiency might be one of the causes
because if you're following doing what
your doctor said and just doing the RDA,
I'm looking right here on my Beyond
Tangy Tangerine here. Um, if you if
you're doing just what the doctor says
and you're, you know, just taking the 10
milligrams or 50 milligrams from a
multivitamin, you're not getting enough
thin. You want to hear something
interesting? When I was do I when I was
drinking alcohol during my alcohol
drinking days,
I would carry supplements with me. I
carry an anacetylcysteine with me and I
carry B vitamins with me and I carry
thamin with me and a lot of it. Oops,
hang on a second. Um, and a lot of it.
And in the middle of the night, I would
take them and then when I went to bed at
night, I would take them and they're
incredible for hangovers.
And you know what I didn't do when I was
drinking? I would not go to Denny's and
eat pancakes and potatoes, you know, and
French fries.
>> What did you eat? What was your
>> anything? I would be I would be the
weird guy not eating,
you know.
>> My my It's funny because my buddy is a
dentist and he reminds me of you.
>> Yeah. And um he um
he he would
not eat
stand in the kitchen
and be down in the Jack like he could
drink
>> he could drink huh
>> he could drink a whole bottle of Jack
>> Jack Daniels
>> in an evening
>> you know I don't know how I did it tell
you the truth I I couldn't do it again
that's for
I haven't had out I not that I've like
I'm not like a tea totler or anything
but I just haven't had it for years
and the last time I had it I just it
just knocked me out.
>> Okay. Key said, "Is it true that fungal
issues can also be tied to a high toxic
load in the liver?"
>> Everything's high tied to a high toxic
load in the liver. There's no like a
direct relationship like high toxic load
in the liver causes a fungal infection.
But if you have a high toxic load in the
liver, your body's immune system is
likely suppressed. If your body's immune
system is likely suppressed, you're not
going to be able to handle the fun
funguses effectively. So yeah, but you
know, everything is high toxic load in
the liver. That's what all disease is.
That's a triangle of disease
the So yes, it can. But not not like
directly. It's because that puts a load
on the detoxification system. That is a
great book, by the way. Why?
Yeah, I recommended that. That's called
Why Animals Don't Get Heart Attacks.
Exactly. That's written by I think it
was Matias Wrath who wrote that. Um and
and he's right. Do you ever wonder why
animals don't get heart attacks?
>> Because they make their own vitamin C.
>> Yeah. Vitamin C is an incredibly
valuable cardiovascular health nutrient.
That's why they don't There's almost
like a conspiracy against vitamin C
because it's so easy and it's so cheap.
It's like, why aren't they telling
everybody you want grams of that stuff?
Grams of it,
>> you know, not a 100 milligrams. Are you
joking? You know, 100 milligrams of
vitamin C is like
there's 5,000 milligrams of vitamin C in
a teaspoon. So, 100 milligrams is
onetenth of a what is it?
>> It's 1/50th of a teaspoon.
>> Are you kidding me? That's you take a
teaspoon, divide it by 50, and that's
how much vitamin C you need. What are
you talking about? That's absurd.
>> It's absurd. So, anyway, I got I got to
get going here. Do we have any other
questions?
>> Uh, Becca says rabbits have heart
attacks. Um,
>> uh, rabbits have heart attacks.
>> That's what she's saying. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't know if that's true.
>> Um, you want to hear something funny
about rabbits? When they were
determining the relationship between
cholesterol and heart disease,
they did it by use by feeding rabbits
lots of meat
or lots of cholesterol, I should say.
Not meat, but lots maybe with meat, but
lots of cholesterol. Rabbits don't eat
cholesterol. They're vegetarians. And
so, lo and behold, when the rabbits got
heart attacks, they said, "Oh, it's the
cholesterol." No, it's not. It was the
It was That's a classic scam in the uh
in the annals of medical history. That's
one of the most classic scams there was
was feeding rabbits cholesterol and then
when they got heart attacks blaming the
cholesterol instead of the
>> and their herbivores.
>> And their herbivores. Exactly.
>> Hey, Pharmacist Ben, let's wrap it up.
Give Give people a bit of advice as far
as how to help their aging uh family and
kin and how they can do it as a coach.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Eat less food. Look for
other ways to entertain yourself. eat
food to um bond or to improve our mood,
to reduce our cortisol. Come up with
other ways to reduce your cortisol, to
bond, to improve your mood. That's one
of the most important things you could
do is eat less food. Eat check in with
your belly when you eat. That's probably
the most important dietary thing I could
say. Drink Beyond Tangy Tangerine every
day. Make sure you do a little bit of
exercise every day. Make sure you figure
out how to activate the rest and digest
parasympathetic nervous system through
slow deep breathing, muscle relaxation,
gratitude, warm water. You know what a
really easy way to activate the
parasympathetic nervous system? Hum. Do
you know humming is one of the most
incredible health strategies? You you
send these vibrations to to all the
liquids inside your head. You know what
I'm talking about? you. It's an amazing
to activate the parasympathetic nervous
system, parasympathetic nervous system,
you know, like
>> same thing, same thing. Vibrate,
vibrate,
>> vibrate. And it also vibrates the oxygen
in your mouth and then that
>> absolutely stimulates the blood flow,
stimulates oxygen. sighing going like
this
is that's another way you could activate
the parasympathetic nervous system. How
would we keep weight on the mus on what
on the
>> on the older folks our older family
>> uh resistance training in combination
with TMR shake and protein resistance
training. You don't need to go to the
gym. You can just do isometrics,
isotonics,
rub bands, you know, $5 on Amazon for
bands. You put on your feet and you
could do like sit-ups. You do back
exercises, calisthenics, yoga.
Stretching [snorts]
is so important for older people. Uh but
for putting on weight, you need
resistance training. You don't want to
put on weight. Nobody wants to put on
weight. People want to put on muscle
mass. If you want to put on weight, just
go eat pizza every day and ice cream and
and cake. You know, that's not the
problem. Putting on weight. Putting on
muscle. You want lean muscle mass is
what you're looking for and that's
resistance training.
>> And should people become a health coach?
>> And ketogenic and ketogenic diet and
fasting and yes being a health coach is
great. Ketogenic diet and fasting and
resistance training. Uh that that's that
would be my strategies for um for
building muscle when you're older uh or
any age. And then also um the health
coach is great. It's a a great thing for
you to do just for yourself, let alone
the people you can help, let alone how
good it's gonna be for business. It's
just good to do it for yourself so you
can understand how your body works.
>> Yes, I'm a fan of the health coach
program.
>> Well, Mrs. Ben, I appreciate you. You on
Friday with us on dealing with Doc.
>> Can't wait.
>> You can't
wait.
Uh, I'm glad you made it home in one
piece and I I would like to maybe talk
to you offline about uh
>> Call me Call me tonight.
>> See you soon, my friend.
>> Okay, buddy.
>> You man. Thank you.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Huh? [music]
Hey. Hey.
>> [music]
>> Where are you? [music]